shut up an endo pure food knocks on all
the logs and cameras Plus does this
[Music]
Westworld is back and along with it my
terrible intros in this video we'll be
taking a deep dive into episode 1 of
season 3 and if you're new to the
channel in these breakdowns we go over
possible theories explanations and
hidden details littered throughout the
episode so grab an expensive glass of
booze because here we go over this
futuristic map showing the coordinates
to bhai China I want to take a moment to
talk about the title of the episode part
jet domine
which is from a Latin chant that
translates to spare Lord spare your
people be not angry with us forever it's
pretty foreboding since the season we'll
see Dolores attempting to overthrow
humanity now this map here which we'll
see used multiple times throughout the
episode pinpoints locations as well as
divergences and anomalies making me
think this is somehow linked to Rehoboam
heads up I'm gonna screw up saying that
name a million times it's a futuristic
device that was able to strategize a way
to defeat climate change but we'll get
more into what this thing is a bit later
on we're off the coast of China with
this guy Jerry who owns an insane amount
of stocks and ellos the company that
owns Westworld he's just receiving news
about the massacre which transpired at
the end of season two meaning stocks
have plummeted and he's lost a [ __ ] ton
of money
notice here an ad for insight Jerry here
used to work for them the same company
that created Rio Boehm and also the one
Liam Dempsey works for just before bed
he takes a single dose of mellow sunset
which is a limbic mood stabiliser will
see other characters in the show like
Caleb's mother and this party go or use
it which leads me to believe it may play
a bigger role throughout the season if
you want to know more about it the
insight Inc website has more information
and I'll leave a link to that in the
description
Jiri is greeted by Dolores we last saw
in Charlotte's body leaving West world
at the end of season 2 now not a lot of
time has passed since that event so it's
likely Dolores in Charlotte's body
remade a copy of herself and transferred
her consciousness back into
original body this was likely done using
Arnold's host creation machine in his
home it would also explain how she was
able to create this copy of Martin who
we'll get into in a bit Dolores
remembers Gerry from his visit to West
world where he sexually abused her so
this is personal she's stolen his money
to fund what she calls an investment
into the origin of a new species meaning
the hosts taking over but what she
really wants are his confidential files
he has on in sight since insight owns
Rio Boehm and AI with immense power she
is likely looking to take control of it
in her effort to take over the world
with the files acquired Gerry does a big
swing and a miss dying in the pool with
his wife asking Dolores who she is
just like Dolores was freed from the
violence of Westworld so too was Jerry's
wife from his abuse Dolores is
interaction with Jerry here hints that
she is using her knowledge of past park
guests to manipulate control and perhaps
even replace people in prominent
positions in the real world moving to
Los Angeles we get our first look at
Caleb Nichols
he's a down-and-out construction worker
who rigs fiber-optic cable with a robot
for a living the first episode really
sets him up as this disillusioned young
man with a dying mother in the hospital
unable to pay the bills and they trauma
involving an ex-army buddy all melding
together to make this character even
questions how technology was supposed to
make the world better but sometimes he's
not so sure this worldview will
definitely come into play when he teams
up with Dolores who wants to tear it all
down we also learned that he is in a
very small minority of people who don't
have an implant now we're not exactly
sure what this entails but it's likely
these implants are connected with Rio
bone him not having an implant will help
him later on we also get this voiceover
of Caleb's ex-army mate Francis played
by Kid Cudi at the end of the episode
we'll find out he's actually dead and
this is all part of a futuristic
treatment program meant for Caleb to get
over his trauma
Caleb's unwillingness to talk with
Francis shown through his continual
refusal to pick up his calls shows his
inability to move on with his life
and confront his trauma in fact at the
end of the episode he unsubscribes to
the treatment which his therapist says
if he does he won't get his benefits so
look for him being even more strapped
for cash in the episodes ahead in the
hospital we see Caleb's mother who
doesn't even recognize her own son
hinting that she may have Alzheimer's if
he can't pay her bills she'll be forced
to move to a shittier state-run facility
this is when he uses an app called reco
which is like uber for committing crimes
hooking up criminals of various kinds to
partake in heists sheikh towns and
thefts reco is short form for Racketeer
Influenced and Corrupt Organizations his
first mission is to pick up a canister
of acetylene which he uses to blow up an
ATM machine alongside ash and giggles
giggles here has a cool shirt which
lights up depending on how he's feeling
when he's on drugs it's amused when he
gets punched in the face angry in San
Francisco Charlotte heads a dello sport
meeting three months after the massacre
at West world already the show is
playing around with time since the first
scene of this episode was shortly after
the massacre and boom and now or three
months later I'm going out on a limb
here and saying this is not Dolores and
Charlotte's body but one of the five
pearls which contains individual host
data that she took off the island it
seems as though Charlotte will be
managing the dello side of things while
Dolores will be handling insight how
these two come together in Dolores
master plan we'll just have to find out
as the show comes along Charlotte here
is the interim CEO and wants to take the
company private which the other board
members think is suicide she can only
pass something with the approval of the
Machine proxy an algorithm that makes
decisions on behalf of someone who we
don't know it's not mentioned who this
person is but my guess is it might be
William aka the man in black it's also
here that we learn a worldwide manhunt
is underway to find Bernard who was
rebuilt by Dolores at the end of season
two Bernard is in the Philippines we can
tell by the Filipino signs in the
background he's working at a meat
production plant under the name
Armand Delgado which is an anagram for
damaged Arnold and spends most of his
time at night running Diagnostics on
himself paranoid Dolores may be
interfering with his coding but what
really is interesting about Bernard is
his ability to switch between two
seemingly different operating systems
we'll see him later take on two of his
coworkers and brutally attack them then
switch back into his more peace
form it's also here he tells them that
without someone to help him he can't
trust himself this is why at the end of
the episode he wants to travel back to
west world there is someone there that
can help him make sense of all this
perhaps it's Ford or some iteration of
him his ability to switch into these two
forms leads me to believe Dolores might
to be able to manipulate his violent
form later on in the season after all
she was the one who brought him back
also curious is when he asked himself a
question he says would you ever lie to
me Bernard almost as if someone else is
controlling him and here's a kick-ass
dress change goddamn Dolores here is on
her way to see Liam Dempsey at insight
who's being awarded technologist of the
Year for helping curb climate change he
refers to Dolores as Laura and she also
tells one of Liam's friends she's from a
small town out west which is a fun
tongue-in-cheek nod to Wes world after a
brief chat with Liam's friends one of
whom questions whether or not we're
living in a simulation within a
simulation a hint that this entire
season might actually be a simulation
Liam is pulled aside by Martin Connells
his head of security and informed that
he must make a very important meeting
Dolores is of course listening in on
this she needs to get close to Liam for
reasons that will be made clear in a
moment at a therapy session Caleb
questions his treatment but what I find
more curious here are his flashbacks
featuring Francis one in which they're
clearly in uniform the other where he's
not but we can make out what appears to
be a Russian sign over here whether this
was a special operation or something
more criminal isn't yet known but I
doubt this will be the last time we
visit the whole Caleb Francis backstory
Caleb once again refuses a call from the
fake Francis program and resorts to
doing another Rico mission for the
second time Caleb mentions he doesn't do
personals ie missions that involve
harming others it's basically the
writers trying to show us that yeah
Caleb does some shady [ __ ] but he'd
never hurt anyone
plus it will create some great tension
when he later joins up with Dolores who
basically beats the [ __ ] out of everyone
speaking of Dolores she's getting off
Liam's giant yacht near the coast of
California and we get our first glimpse
of Rehoboam the few clues we get about
it happened in this scene Liam basically
talks about how his dad thought that if
everyone had a purpose in life their own
path the world would be a better place
so real boom charts that course for you
likely by taking all your data your
desires habits everything about you to
predict your actions and know what is
best for you of course we'll likely see
how this can be manipulated and used for
nefarious purposes
Rehoboam is a reference to the grandson
of King David who faced a rebellion
resulting in a fractured Israel
we'll likely be seeing a fractured world
if Dolores has her way
after Liam is whisked away for his super
top secret meeting Dolores chases after
him to eavesdrop learning that this
Asian woman over here represents a yet
unknown man who has interest in real
woman that someone may have gained
access to it Liam says it's not possible
and that her boss should be more
interested in what's going on over at
Delos meaning that there is some sort of
link between her boss insight and ellos
now we don't know who this person is it
could potentially be serac who we'll get
to in a bit caleb gets a call from this
straight-and-narrow job he applied for
only to find out he's rejected not only
that the person who rejected him was an
AI this is all laying the foundation for
his character this season his contempt
for technology and inability to fit into
society will lead him to do things
others would not at Liam's multi-million
dollar condo Liam vents his frustration
about REO boom wishing he could just
turn it off the big revelation here is
that he's never had control of it and
that his father's partner locked him out
of the system right after his father's
death years ago more frightening he has
no idea what it's planned the only
person who does is his father's partner
but before Dolores can find out who this
is
she's tased by Martin who has found out
Dolores isn't who she says she is
perhaps she's looking to steal money or
into Liam for industrial espionage they
don't know she's actually a host Martin
and Liam decide to get rid of her by
drugging and dumping her body meanwhile
Caleb takes on a new Rico mission
delivering tranquilizers to a man
working for Martin this is where caleb
and Dolores story lines begin to collide
he shoot away and Dolores is given
lethal amounts of tranquilizer which of
course don't work on her when a
mysterious vehicle pulls up providing
enough of a distraction for her to take
out the entire security force
Martin drives off but is chased by
Dolores and ultimately shot and killed
by a replica of him my guess is that
this new Martin who will likely act as a
mole at insite now is actually Teddy her
lover from Westworld and this is also
where Martin reveals
partner is serac Neal this character is
played by vincent cassell and is likely
extremely wealthy from the trailers we
know he somehow teams up with me and
tries to get her to stop dolores caleb
unsubscribes from his treatment saying
that he'll need to find something or
someone real in order to get on with his
life
this is rape before he'll meet a shot
dolores the irony here is that she isn't
real at all Bernard here now with this
shaved beard asked some local boaters to
take him to West world meaning that West
world might just be on an island or even
crazier underwater somewhere in the
South China Sea off the coast of the
Philippines and finally I hope you
stayed around for the post-credits scene
which reveals Maeve in a world war 2
themed park set in Nazi controlled Italy
my best guess here is that Maeve has
been reprogrammed by Delos and moved to
this new park and has been here for
quite some time however when she wakes
up she's snapping into her old memory
that's why when she sees the prisoner
she has no recollection of who he is but
the bruises on her knuckles and his
scared reaction hint that she was the
one who beat the crap out of him she'll
be diverging from her path here looking
for a way out
that's it for this episode I can't wait
to see how this season shapes up and I'm
sure there's a bunch of stuff I didn't
cover so leave your thoughts and
theories in the comments below I'll be
covering every episode the season so be
sure to LIKE and subscribe with the bail
on you can also follow me on twitter at
things story whitey
until next time remember daddy loves you
very much